[Laughter]
everyone knows actors and actresses deal
with the stress of hair and makeup on
set
but did you ever think that their
on-screen makeup and prosthetics
might be taking a toll on them anyone
who wears makeup knows just how annoying
putting it on and taking it all off
again can be
but wait till you see the painstaking
process that these 15 actors were put
through
in their makeup transformations to make
you feel truly grateful for your own
makeup routine
stick around to see how these actors and
actresses dealt with these sticky
makeovers
after 20 different makeup tests to find
the perfect shade of blue for jennifer
lawrence's character mystique the
process of completing this actress's
makeup for the x-men film
was already proving to be challenging
can you believe it took six girls seven
hours to fully paint the actress's body
every woman knows as our dream come true
in order to keep herself up and adam
during the application process
lawrence would either stand or work out
on a bicycle to keep her blood pumping
not only was lawrence's full blue
bodysuit of makeup arduous to get on
but it was painful to keep on as the
actress reported the blue paint to be
irritating to her skin
causing boils and blisters to her
complexion apparently they've simplified
the bluing of you turns out they never
had to do eight hours of full-blown body
paint ever
as much as the prosthetics used on anya
chalatra may have added to her role on
the set of the witcher
the very same prosthetics that enhanced
her acting abilities
also caused her physical harm and the
costume and the blood
and the sweat
after being fitted with a hunchback to
make her character that much more
believable the star fell victim to a
pulled nerve
causing her lots of pain the thickness
of her costume caused
even more sweaty discomfort that the
actress had to deal with during her time
on set
she even said i have a trapped nerve in
my back that i had to get massaged out
after playing her for so long
it was very uncomfortable not much for
this beast
[Music]
from a full-blown headcast to hours of
makeup
it's no wonder anne hathaway needed to
vent about her makeup experience for the
witch's movie
she took to instagram and called her
makeup look her resting witch face
after sitting through having her whole
head enveloped in
whatever that is in order to mold her
facial prosthetics
hathaway must have needed to take a
well-deserved breather from her makeup
process
if you notice you know in the length of
the video because it's a time lapse i
got stuck
after insisting upon the use of
prosthetics herself angelina jolie was
fitted with cheek
nose ear and teeth prosthetics to bring
her character in maleficent to life
angelina stated in an interview we
didn't want her to be
somebody that when you were staring at
her during a real dramatic scene
that you were distracted by her makeup
so it had to be extreme but her soul had
to come out
despite its simplicity this makeup look
took a full three hours to apply and one
hour to take off
every day and jolie wore it for 16 hours
at a time
ouch and it was like living out some
childhood fantasy you know that being in
such
intense makeup for his role as vision
was in no way comfortable
as paul bettany is seen ripping off his
full-face makeup which
might be the most painful part of the
process this makeup look takes the actor
only an hour and a half of application
time
not too shabby compared to some of the
other actors on this list
the most uncomfortable part of betany's
prosthetic setup is his lack of hearing
with makeup artists having to make
adjustments to his prosthetics in order
for him to be able to hear at all
i didn't think for a minute what that
was actually going to mean to me
physically ryan reynolds painful makeup
application for his character deadpool
was truly grueling because of the time
that went into the look
reynolds was a good sport maybe even too
good of a sport
as he pranked his makeup artist by
ripping off his facial prosthetics after
hours of application i'm not gonna do it
right you know there's no
point in doing it at all during john
reese davey's startling transformation
into gimli
the actor had to face terrible makeup
processes which left him barely able to
see and made his skin break out in an
allergic reaction
the lord of the rings actor had to work
on alternate days in order to give his
skin a break from the harsh makeup
process
you can't really see my brows moving all
the rest of it
in order to transform lead actor jacob
tremblay into a boy with the genetic
disorder treacher colin syndrome
makeup artists needed full body
prosthetics to make it work
the makeup itself took an hour and a
half of painfully meticulous application
and suited jacob up in a full head of
prosthetics no way is it comfortable
wearing a fake face and head for nine
whole hours of shooting it was like
there was a nice cozy warm cocoon around
your head
game of thrones is known for its
creative and interesting character
design
kai alexander's role as leaf was no
exception to this imaginative creativity
the most painful thing about this
makeover process was definitely its run
time
as kai had to sit for nearly 10 hours to
get this makeup on and ready for the
spotlight
i sat in a chair for 10 hours top to
bottom
including the wig even makeup artist
david white calls nebula's makeup look
the most complex and interesting of any
of the characters in guardians of the
galaxy
it was very challenging especially on a
female had to be
sexy and kind of comic book but
believable
this makeup look was so intense it took
five hours of application and
even required karen to shave her head
she knew this going into the audition
process
but didn't really get a chance to
process the bald-headed change until she
got the role
i don't know if dedication to a makeup
look gets more uncomfortable than that
and i might have done something a little
bit crazy
this not very well known actress has had
an even less well-known transformation
into pepper from american horror story
asylum
the makeup look that transformed her
into pepper takes about three hours and
two makeup artists
including blinding her in one eye with a
contact lens and setting her up with a
pair of fake teeth
imagine sitting in makeup for three
hours and then having to walk around
half blind afterwards
how uncomfortable i want pbi
the most uncomfortable part of
vladimir's transformation into the night
king in the game of thrones series
has to be the six and a half you heard
me six and a half
hours of sitting in the makeup chair
then once in full night king garb
the actor had to remember not to blink
while in character
the combo of painstaking makeup
application and these intense stage
directions
definitely made for an uncomfortable
experience on the game of thrones set
it looks like easy but
it's definitely not so easy
another leading woman who had to deal
with the absolute torture of full body
makeup application
is zoe saldana in her role as gamora in
guardians of the galaxy
just like jlaw she had to deal with the
trials and tribulations of many color
tests to get her to be the perfect shade
of green
the marvel franchise star revealed just
how long it took to apply all of her
makeup
over three hours and with the help of
two separate makeup artists
zoe is quoted saying the whole coming
together of gamora every morning
that was a little grueling famous
actress haley berry played six different
characters in cloud atlas
so it's surprising that you may have
never even seen it her makeup
transformation into six
different identities was surely an
uncomfortable hassle
as the actress also had to deal with a
recently broken foot
on set her makeup artist jeremy woodhead
is quoted saying
even with all the discomfort she was
going through it was necessary to the
story of each character
that part was thrilling as an actor and
a huge challenge
one of the most well-known makeup movie
jobs in history
has also been one of the most
uncomfortable when transforming into the
grinch
jim carrey is known for being irritated
by yellow contact lenses
being restrained by his full bodysuit
and needing the help of a torture
specialist
to get through the movie shoot it was
when i did the grinch
i was uh literally the makeup was like
being buried alive every day
the next time you watch a movie or
television show with intensely creative
looking characters
think about how much time and pain went
into their looks before you judge their
acting
it might make you appreciate them that
much more thanks for watching
give this video a big thumbs up and
subscribe to the things for more great
content about your favorite tv shows and
movies
we'll see you next time